for more on the fallout from the firing
of James Comey we're joined by CBS News
justice reporter Paula Reid she's in our
Washington bureau Paula good morning
good morning
Paula Democrats are raising the specter
of possible intimidation and obstruction
of justice what exactly are the legal
ramifications here Anthony at this point
we don't have enough evidence in the
public record to support obstruction of
justice you would need to prove that the
president knew what he was doing was
going to impact the investigation
sources are telling us that in a lot of
ways what's happened over the past few
days has invigorated FBI investigators
it's important to note there is another
crime and that is lying to the FBI that
is a crime so anyone who's interviewed
in the course of this investigation they
need to make sure that they have their
facts straight before they talk to
investigators otherwise that is a chart
that could stick Paula we're starting to
hear names to replace direct former
director Comey what can you tell us
about them and what will be expected of
them well earlier in the week the
Attorney General and his deputy rod
Rosen Stein they interviewed four
candidates all top level counter
intelligence officials currently serving
in government and then today they're
going to interview a more diverse pool
of candidates among them as Senator John
Cornyn and also two lesser known names a
lawyer named Alice Fisher and also a
judge Michael Garcia out of New York now
both of them have previously held top
Department of Justice jobs one other
name is also the current acting director
of the FBI Andrew McCabe the president
is not trying to find someone who is
qualified but will also not look like
he's trying to replace Comey
with one of his cronies so they're
looking at all these candidates and more
but these are the eight that we know
have or will be interviewed later today
all a read in our Washington bureau
thank you Paul